why is the country as fat as the country
I mean the country is it's a public
health crisis where everybody
everybody's like four or five hundred
pounds I mean not everybody but you go
to middle America
these are big noise you go to Disneyland
they're what happened it's bad what is
it and and you're a guy from that world
a little bit what how do you fix it what
world for the world of somebody whose
works out and is yeah just people are
lazy so it's like if you want food it's
like fast food to everywhere so the
government kind of [ __ ] us and just
society [ __ ] is because if you want
food it's like these things do is stop
at Burger King suddenly like the healthy
options are more expense if they're
harder to get so it's like already tough
to eat healthy then there's no healthy
option what do you think about this
whole thing about fat shaming and that
we're now celebrating fat people like I
don't celebrate fat people I can't like
the models I don't want my model fat
that's not what they do right that it's
a good point it's not what the hell what
about Liz oh because Lucille is very
very popular whose weight but lose
weight yeah it lose a little it was a
lot like her attitude good for her like
not good liar but I which is unhealthy
but have you seen a new video where she
comes out in the diabetic boots I like
that the point is she needs to get
skinny she's gonna explode and her
entrails are gonna hit the faces why I'm
into blood on our hands because no one's
like you go fat girl it's like I'm the
only one going you don't go fat girl I
need to just take it down and I in maybe
I'm not saying it's skinny yeah unless
you get help rein it I mean check your
blood pressure she used to do something
she called out some postmates cuz
opposed me it was late with her food or
something on Twitter so that's a prop
that makes sense it's a problem if
you're if you call not if you're a
multi-millionaire and you're calling and
a post made on she's an addict it's in
it's in a dig it's an addictive listen
I've been there
where's your food of choice when the
post bait shows up I want to strangle
them oh me too
I go yeah down was you have other orders
no I get being angry to post me but then
to call Matt on Twitter is like oh
you're [ __ ] not even in your right
mind my food of choice I'd want your
go-to I don't know if I was a goat you
like my prod like what's a problem like
for me a real real like thing that I
should not have it's like if I maybe I
find myself in Larchmont Village oh
there's a salt & straw oh there's a
scoop ice cream these are bad this house
be like really good ice cream for me to
go there yeah I
garbage I mean either but I finna
Jenny's yeah it's fine it's nice it's
fine salt straws the numero uno so it
was better the salted malted chocolate
cookie dough or whatever favor a stream
and then I get fudge on top I mean this
is and then I walk around Hancock Park
my mouth is watering by the way but sure
like my ice creams always been a bad
thing I actually don't eat like that
like I don't need DOM and I don't need
garbage food but when I go out nice like
meatball no I eat all that I'll be in
New York well let's say let's say and I
mean let's say like you get done tonight
hyenas like like after we after I'm done
with you before instead of getting stuck
in traffic on the way back to Fort Worth
we might go to a steak house and that's
not bad I can eat good there sure but
maybe some maybe the waiter says
something about like lobster bisque or
something I gotta have it maybe I get a
bowl of you're right
see I Google Road lines and while
slowing to four-star restaurants I grew
up eating you grow rich not rich no not
rich my uncle was in the restaurant
business I might he had a lot of great
restaurants in New York so we were just
the only luxury I ever had as a kid food
was food and that was the only thing
that I learned it like high-end stuff I
could go to really nice restaurant so
I've internalized that palette is my
palette is high all right when I was
eight years old I was eating a parfait
of salmon tuna tartare with creme
fraiche and caviar I was like is this a
stereo caviar